we also need to add into the equation
when we talk about Jill Stein that she
is chosen a running mate for vice
president who is a total extremist if
you regularly watch her listen to this
show you know this is not a show where I
will cheerlead anything that has a
supposedly progressive stamp on it if
you want to show like that there are
many shows like that okay I don't even
need to name them for you you can find
those I am going to be completely
upfront that when there is a critique I
need to make of something that is
supposedly progressive I will make it
and Jill Stein has chosen a jammu Baraka
as her running mate for the presidency
on the Green Party ticket we've already
talked about Jill Stein's anti-science
views the Green Party's Pro homeopathy
views okay fine
what about a jammu Baraka well he's
written that President Obama and other
members of the black petite bourgeoisie
are merely puppets living proof that the
white supremacist machine has hijacked
the minds of black people okay also
wrote an article on his blog titled
Paris attacks and the white lives matter
movement where he argues that France
Belgium and other nations that have been
affected by terrorism effectively got
what they deserved
saying while the victims of the violence
in Paris may have been innocent france
was not he wrote because the crimes
committed against Arabs Muslims and
Africans and the horrors of colonialism
and the concerted effort by the French
and US authorities to fund extremist
groups in the Middle East are to blame
for the woes of Western societies
according to Baraka the Sanders campaign
didn't offer a genuine program for
radical change I mean they were talking
about free education government provided
health care that apparently was not
radical enough because it was tacitly
committed to Eurocentrism and as he says
the Bernie Sanders campaign normalized
white supremacy
he's written on his blog that Syrian
leader Bashar al-assad isn't a bad guy
who was after all reelected by big
margins and that he is not engaged in
any war crimes against his people
demonstrably untrue he went on Kevin
Barrett's truth jihad podcast which is
basically a 9/11 truther podcast and
said that
the some recent airline crashes were
false flags that the Democratic Party is
white supremacists and he is also saying
that the u.s. is intentionally
supporting Isis now we've talked about
how weapons get to groups that the u.s.
claims to oppose but to flat-out say the
u.s. is flat-out supporting Isis is a
bit further than most rational clear
thinkers are willing to go if this is
the liberal hero of the supposedly
miraculous Green Party Louis I want
nothing to do with it this is an
extremist you would never think that he
would be part of the Green Party in any
way rightfully if you just yeah read
what he was about unbelievable
maybe he was just picked because Jill
Stein no she's not going to win but this
is someone who maybe could get her more
votes votes that she might not otherwise
have okay who does this guy really
appeal to that's what I'm trying to
figure out anybody who truly analyzes
what this individual has written and
said and identifies as a progressive
there's a fundamental clash there I
don't know how you could say I am a true
progressive and after reading what
Ujamaa Baraka has read and said over
time that's who I want to support I
don't get it so you all know I voted for
Bernie Sanders and you all know very
clearly that I am NOT supporting the
Stein Baraka ticket in November bring on
the hate tell me where I am wrong we
will take a break I've talked about how
people of all ages but particularly
Millennials are owning cars less and
participating more in the sharing
economy and one of the more popular
options is Zipcar which gets you a car
when you want it when you need it they
offer all sorts of cars SUVs hybrids
whatever you need it includes insurance
and it includes gas you just pay for the
time that you actually use the car and
you can reserve the car online from your
smartphone over the phone then you
unlock it with your zip card each car
share member reduces their personal co2
emissions by between 1100 and 1600
pounds per year for our audience
Zipcar is offering 20
five dollars of free driving credit if
you sign up at join Zipcar comm slash
david support our show reduce your
carbon emissions and you're spending on
cars
sign up at join Zipcar comm slash david